I know a lot of people who read way more
than I do and I also know a lot of
people who don't read at all I mean they
haven't read a book since since College
essentially to me it's almost like the
amount I get from it it's almost like a
secret weapon where when I think you
know in two or three or four hundred
Pages which I can read in whatever 10
days or however long it takes reading 30
pages a day
the amount of information
insights into so many aspects of the
human psyche that I can get it's sort of
like it's not like I'm in a competition
for anything in particular with anybody
I just do my show but it's sort of like
if I'm reading dozens of books a year
and you're reading zero I'm exposed to
so many different things and ideas that
are not even in your Universe it just
seems like the the power of reading just
seems overwhelming